super bowl 55. shireen i made my pick
earlier today anyone that watched the
show this morning and thank you if you
did knows that i went box 30 chiefs 27
because i picked the bucks to win the
super bowl before the season started
it's i think the first time at least
it's the first time i can remember that
i got the super bowl winner actually in
the super bowl which seems odd i i had
to have picked the patriots one of those
i had to have but the i don't remember
any so i'm i'm pretending this is the
first time so i'm not jumping off the
bandwagon bucks 30 chiefs 27 who do you
have
well i gave you the okay too mike to to
change your pick i'm glad to see you
stick with your original pick that that
works out probably better because now
you're keeping
yeah probably so well i picked the bucks
to look i had to go the other way
because i picked the bucks to lose to
the ravens in the super bowl before the
year started so i can't pick the bucks
now right by the same premise so i
didn't but i have an overtime super bowl
i pick the chiefs to win 37-31 in
overtime in the super bowl which would
be one of the greatest super bowls of
all time i think
now is this a first possession touchdown
by the chiefs or
is it brady gets a shot and it doesn't
work out and the chiefs drive down and
score a touchdown
no i think we're going to have patrick
mahomes going down the score and the
reason there was there was thought
behind my reasoning of 37 points because
as we know patrick mahomes has averaged
36.1 points in his postseason career and
games he started and finished throwing
out that browns game earlier this year
so i i had to pick over 36 points and
this would be fitting because patrick
holmes was denied an appearance in the
super bowl in his first year as a
starter in an overtime game where he
didn't get a chance to touch the ball
and you know what's funny
i always thought you know they changed
the overtime rule after the viking
saints nfc championship in 2009 when the
saints had a good kick off return they
got a couple of questionable calls there
was a a pass interference and before
that there was an illegal contact or
defensive holding or one of those things
down you know that helped the saints
keep the drive alive they changed over
time then but still even though a field
goal won't allow you to walk off as the
winner in a sudden death capacity a
touchdown does we had super bowl 51
decided on a first drive touchdown in
overtime we had the afc championship two
years ago decided on a first drive
touchdown in overtime i don't think
they're ever going to change it even if
it would happen again um biggest factor
for me in this game i think there's
going to be a big play by the buccaneers
defense probably devin white one or two
of them that's going to be the thing
that provides the difference for the for
the bucks what's the difference maker
for you
well that's what it's going to take for
the bucks to win this game and i don't
think patrick mahomes makes any mistakes
in this game i think he's mvp has a
great game and proves unstoppable mike
in this game and he's going to be the
difference the mvp yet again
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports